[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be once
again discussing sirius black
albus dumbledore and azkaban prison in
one of my last videos i discussed sirius
black's imprisonment
and why i felt that he was never
properly exonerated for his
alleged crimes crimes which were of
course committed by peter pettigrew
in 1981 shortly after voldemort had just
been defeated
black tracked pettigrew down and found
him in a small muggle town
it was in this town that petticrew
murdered 12 muggles using a dark and
powerful blasting curse
simultaneously destroying hundreds of
feet of sewer system
and leaving a 40-foot crater in the
ground after this happened pettigrew cut
off part of his right index finger
and escaped into the sewers in his
animagus form a rat
this is how serious black was framed for
pettigrew's crimes
however more specifically i addressed
why i thought it was that sirius was
kept in azkaban
for such a long time 12 years sirius was
a member of the order of the phoenix
and dumbledore was its leader surely
dumbledore one of the wisest wizards of
all time
and a legitimacy master could have
figured out sirius's innocence
unless of course he didn't want to in
this video
i'm going to be exploring the
possibility that dumbledore knew of
sirius's innocence all along
but allowed sirius to rot in prison it's
a bit of a morbid theory
but i think that it has some merit and
honestly may have been possible
after sirius was sentenced to his crimes
the whole wizarding world turned on him
he was immediately featured on the front
cover of the daily prophet
and the whole visiting world was exposed
to sirius black
mass murderer however i feel like sirius
got no slack when it came to his
sentencing
particularly as up until that point in
time he had lived a fairly normal life
series began attending hogwarts in the
year 1971
along with fellow marauders peter
pettigrew james potter and remus lupin
he was a good student though a bit of a
troublemaker and was sorted into
gryffindor house when he started at the
school
after graduating he joined the order of
the phoenix which was founded by albus
dumbledore
and helped with the opposition against
lord voldemort and the death eaters
so my question is how could everyone
truly believe that sirius was a murderer
he had spent a considerable amount of
time with his fellow order members
and during his time at hogwarts shawley
would have made an impression on some of
his professors
so why did everyone suddenly believe
that he had the capacity to murder 12
muggles and his lifelong friend
unfortunately when sirius was initially
caught for his alleged crimes
he sort of sealed his own fate when
instead of pleading his innocence
his first reaction was to burst out
laughing with the pile of dead muggles
and the index finger of his friend in
front of him
sirius should have taken his situation
very seriously but
in times of extreme stress it's hard to
predict how one will react unable to
process everything that had just
happened
sirius had a mental breakdown the
potters were dead he had just witnessed
the murder of 12 muggles
his childhood friend pettigrew changed
allegiance
and from that point onward he would have
to live knowing the recommendation that
he'd made to the potters to make
pettigrew secret keeper
sirius was possibly the main reason that
the potters had died
and he couldn't process everything that
had just happened sirius was of course
the initial choice for the plot of
secret keeper
a witch or wizard designated to hide a
secret secured by the fidelius charm
which conceals the secret inside of the
secret keeper's soul
however pettigrew was later chosen as
secret keeper in his place
as sirius felt that he would have been a
more likely target for voldemort
lily and james only made you secret
keeper because i suggested it
i thought it was the perfect plan
voldemort would be sure to come after me
you'd never dream they'd use a weak
talentless thing like you
it must have been the finest moment of
your miserable life telling voldemort
you could hand him the potters
however this was a fatal error on
sirius's part as pettigrew
after being made secret keeper showed
his true colours
because sirius and the potters had never
revealed to anyone else the change in
secret keeper
from the outside it honestly looked as
though serious had first given up the
potter's location to voldemort
then murdered a bunch of muggles then
killed pettigrew things didn't look good
for sirius
and when fudge showed up to the scene of
the crime and witnessed syria's laughing
he looked like a crazed murderous
lunatic that was truly befitting of the
crimes that had just been committed
his laughter rid him of whatever shred
of innocence he may have otherwise had
and he was sent to azkaban without a
trial
this is unheard of particularly because
death eaters who'd committed equally
horrible crimes
even got to trial given that sirius was
in the eyes of fudge
unequivocally and indisputably guilty
for his crimes
and the fact that he was the last known
secret keeper it's no surprise that he
went to azkaban for 12 years
however what i always found interesting
was that dumbledore didn't step up and
defend sirius
sure dumbledore didn't know about the
change in secret keeper but he did know
sirius
and if there's one thing that dumbledore
exhibits well in this series
it's his ability to read people and read
situations
i find it hard to believe that albus
dumbledore was truly convinced
that sirius was guilty not only that but
dumbledore possesses the means to figure
out whether he's innocent or not
dumbledore is portrayed in the books and
films as being a skilled legitimate
which means that he's essentially able
to read people's minds he does this
first with creature and the order of the
phoenix
and creature told you all this and
laughed he quote he did not wish to tell
me
said dumbledore but i am a sufficiently
accomplished the germans myself
to know when i'm being lied to and i
persuaded him
to tell me the full story before i left
for the department of mysteries
dumbledore was also the chief warlock of
the wazengamot
which gave him access to azkaban inmates
with this access
we know that he also used legitimacy on
morphin gaunt in the past
yes but it took a great deal of skilled
legitimacy to coax it out of him
so my question is couldn't he have
easily just gone to azkaban and found
out the truth dumbledore's word was
enough to have snape's name cleared
so surely if he had found out the truth
he could have done something for sirius
didn't he owe that to him i think that
the potential morbid reality of this
situation
is that dumbledore knew that sirius was
innocent all along but allowed him to be
imprisoned in azkaban
because he felt that his imprisonment
would be better for the wizarding world
as a whole
here's why sirius black was harry's
godfather and
being so close to the potters would have
likely taken young harry under his
wing after the death of his parents if
he were given a trial
i think that it's highly likely that
sirius would have claimed guardianship
over harry
i also think that it's particularly
interesting that sirius never got to
trial at all
particularly as other death eaters did
it seems almost too convenient
that he never got a chance to speak his
case as though one of his allies had
persuaded the ministry
that he was sure of black's guild
dumbledore but
dumbledore never wanted sirius to rot in
azkaban for no reason
he had a purpose and this purpose came
down to baby harry
and what harry would need to achieve
over the course of his lifetime
first of all if sirius had taken
guardianship of harry he would have
never lived with the dursleys
and though they were awful to harry it
may have actually kept him alive
dumbledore explains this himself while
you can still call home the place where
your mother's blood dwells
there you cannot be touched or harmed by
voldemort he shed her blood
but it lives on in you and her sister
her blood became your refuge
you need to return there only once a
year but as long as you can still call
it home
there he cannot hurt you your aunt knows
this i explained what i had done
later i left with you on her doorstep
she knows that allowing you house room
may well have kept you alive for the
past 15 years
and that's why harry lived with dursleys
not because they provided him with a
loving home
and because they were the best fit for
him but because of his bloodline
harry's aunt petunia was of course the
sister of harry's mother
early potter because petunia was harry's
blood relative
people held the belief that lily's act
of sacrificial protection
would continue on and be transmitted
through petunia
so even though the dursleys treated
harry like trash in a tragic turn of
events it was actually still safer with
the dursleys
than with anyone else sirius would have
been a great father figure to harry
and harry would have enjoyed a wonderful
upbringing but he would have never been
completely safe
under the roof of the dursleys harry had
nothing to worry about
or more specifically dumbledore had
harry was the chosen one and he needed
to grow old so the prophecy could come
true
and he could overpower and defeat lord
voldemort dumbledore who lived his life
pursuing the best interest of the
wizarding world as a whole
rather than the best interest of
individuals raised harry
like a pig for sorter knowing that he
would eventually die
in order for harry to fulfill the
prophecy and act as a martyr
dumbledore felt that harry would need to
be raised under harsh conditions
and at the dursley residence harsh
conditions harry faced
had harry been raised by sirius who
would have grown up as a famous
strong confident and independent young
man and perhaps not the man
and martyr that the wizarding world
would end up needing dumbledore
manipulated harry from day one for the
greater good
and serious black would have only gotten
in his way though dumbledore didn't
dislike sirius
in damador's eyes his imprisonment was
essential to secure the fate of the
wizarding world
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think of this theory
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you